hey everyone and welcome back to my
condo today I'm doing a smaller episode
the last time I made a big purchase i
had a new 55 inch TV and today i'm
talking about these little tiny bottle
openers that come from umbra I'm going
to bring them up here so you can see
this one is our beer opener it's got a
little thing here on the back that you
can pop them in like this and he's like
eating your beer and popping the cap
open and this one is our corkscrew and
you can pull it out here and screw it
why I like these two things when i'm
buying something for my place just like
in my business I like to pay attention
to the details and I want something
people are going to talk about I don't
want just a boring beer opener or
corkscrew I want something that people
will talk about I want something that
looks interesting it's modern and
stylish but but will also strike up a
conversation so when I'm buying
something if I'm rushed i'll just buy
something crappy something that just
gets me through the day you know gets me
through whatever urgent scenario i have
but if i have some time I like spending
my time to find something that I really
like and would want to share with people
so these are the two that i bought i
really like their design they only cost
I think $25 combine this one's a little
more because it's two pieces so I want
to say it's like 10 and 15 ish something
around there but those are the two new
additions to my condo and I hope you
guys enjoy will check them out there
from Umbra and pretty affordable and a
funky way to make your living room look
good I've just put them up here on my
bar so it's a talking point of anybody
coming in I still need to fill up my bar
you see I have no alcohol I've got no
glasses don't have much of a party going
on here yet but I have some
show-stopping pieces to talk about
anyway if you guys like this video give
it a thumbs up below you have a question
you want to see something else let me
know in the comments thank you guys and
I'll see you soon